Jordan Patel: Today’s focus: auth rate limiting.
Noah Williams: Any blockers from last time?
Jordan Patel: Let’s aim for a concrete owner and rollout plan.
Samira López: Action: write migration.
Samira López: Risk: scope creep for auth rate limiting.
Riley Chen: From QA perspective, Performance baseline needs to be recorded.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on auth rate limiting; ship a thin slice.
Priya Singh: Risk: data migration for auth rate limiting.
Noah Williams: Let’s capture action items clearly on auth rate limiting.
Riley Chen: Let’s clarify acceptance criteria on auth rate limiting.
Samira López: Risk: data migration for auth rate limiting.
Riley Chen: I propose we split auth rate limiting into two subtasks.
Samira López: My take is we split auth rate limiting into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: We’ll need QA test cases listed on auth rate limiting.
Noah Williams: Action: book design review.
Jordan Patel: Infra-wise, Design feedback is pending.
Jordan Patel: Let’s clarify acceptance criteria on auth rate limiting.
Priya Singh: Edge cases around auth and retries on auth rate limiting.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on auth rate limiting; start with a spike.
Priya Singh: Let’s capture action items clearly on auth rate limiting.
Noah Williams: From design side, We will stage it behind a feature flag.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on auth rate limiting; ship a thin slice.
Noah Williams: Let’s keep this within this sprint on auth rate limiting.
Jordan Patel: I propose we split auth rate limiting into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: Let’s keep this within this sprint on auth rate limiting.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on auth rate limiting; ship a thin slice.
Jordan Patel: We’ll need QA test cases listed on auth rate limiting.
Avery Kim: Action: create test plan.
Jordan Patel: Action: write migration.
Noah Williams: I propose we split auth rate limiting into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on auth rate limiting; start with a spike.
Avery Kim: Risk: data migration for auth rate limiting.
Samira López: Risk: accessibility gaps for auth rate limiting.
Priya Singh: I propose we split auth rate limiting into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: We’ll need QA test cases listed on auth rate limiting.
Priya Singh: Let’s keep this within this sprint on auth rate limiting.
Avery Kim: Risk: flaky tests for auth rate limiting.
Priya Singh: From design side, Security review is likely.
Noah Williams: Action: set up dashboards.
Noah Williams: Infra-wise, We will stage it behind a feature flag.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on auth rate limiting; parallelize testing.
Priya Singh: Infra-wise, Specifically for auth rate limiting.
Riley Chen: Okay, who can take ownership?
Priya Singh: Let’s finalize target date in Jira after this.
Riley Chen: We’ll review outcomes in the next standup.